you
good afternoon my name is Jack Highland
along with Bill record we are co-chairs
of the board of trustees it is my honor
officially to open today's ceremony on
behalf of the entire community of
teachers college I welcome you to the
2011 masters commencement convocation
it's now my pleasure to introduce
president of Teachers College susan h
Fuhrman
good afternoon welcome to convocation at
Teachers College today a feeling of joy
which poet friedrich schiller described
as that bright spark of divinity
permeates this magnificent Cathedral joy
fills the hearts of the unsung heroes
who bore so many sacrifices to make it
to this day the parents partners and
children of our graduates graduates
would you join me stand and turn around
and thank your families
joy touches the hearts of tc's faculty
and staff who have mentored nourished
and nudged our students on their
critical paths all the way to earning
their degrees graduates again please
join me in thanking the faculty and
staff
joy surely dwells in your hearts the
hearts of our graduates who have tested
their ideas and pursued their dreams in
tc's laboratory of knowledge and I am
overjoyed to warmly welcome or graduates
in to tc's alumni fellowship of scholars
and professionals throughout the world
congratulations well done now don't get
too comfortable we are hardly done with
you starting tomorrow we are counting on
you to join our global network of
innovative leaders in the task of
shaping the learning century this will
be your moment education shines is the
coin of the realm in world affairs and
for good reason education drives
innovation and fuels productivity
education is the lifeblood of democracy
and diversity education such as Advanced
Studies and leadership in health and in
teaching lay the foundation for public
and civic health and yet we are all
fighting uphill battles on multiple
fronts to protect this precious currency
we are fighting to reverse a nationwide
high school dropout epidemic that
condemns more than a million American
teenagers a year to lives of poverty
despair and drift we are fighting to
reduce the ever widening gaps in
educational opportunity and scholastic
achievement within our country even as
we simultaneously struggle to catch up
in math and science literacy with other
nations we are fighting a global obesity
epidemic fed by a toxic brew of economic
cultural and behavioral forces the World
Health Organization estimates the global
population of obese people at 300
million roughly the equivalent of the
entire population of the United States
we are also fighting to stem a rising
tide of riddick ridicule suspicion and
anger aimed at the very people on the
front lines who are the best prepared to
tackle and solve society's toughest
problems educated professionals like you
and me in particular teachers leaders
and teacher educators have been unfairly
blamed and often viciously attacked for
the failures of the system itself a
system that fails to distribute an
allocate resources equitably and
effectively a system that doesn't use
existing policy levers to strengthen
weak schools or weak schools of
education but instead Torre's all public
schools and schools of Education with
the same rhetorical brush much of the
public discussion on education has
failed to address or even recognize the
complexity of the challenges we face
instead we get large servings of
simplistic rhetoric that embraces
marginal reforms and experiments as
panaceas when we should be developing
new approaches that can be leveraged
into broad scale improvement simply put
we cannot bicker and blame our way to
success we can and we should put our
heads together pull our perspectives and
specialized areas of expertise and craft
powerful and enduring solutions to the
challenges facing our nation and our
world the talent for blending new ideas
with well grounded knowledge in order to
produce effective new educational
strategies and methods is embedded in
TCS DNA it sparked educational pioneers
such as James Russell John Dewey Edward
Lee Thorndike Margaret Mead and others
to explore new insights into human
development and to develop revolutionary
modalities of teaching and learning
through collaboration and innovation
educational psychology was born here
nutrition education David
dude and the formal preparation of
nurses began here the fields of conflict
resolution comparative and international
education and urban educational theory
and practice were shaped here now we are
on the verge of significant
breakthroughs in the neuro and cognitive
sciences and astonishing advances in
digital technologies that can enhance
learning for all young and old rich and
poor alike meanwhile tc's dynamic
partnerships with local schools in
Harlem and communities throughout the
world will enable us to promote equity
and transform urban education in a time
of scarce resources and through your
leadership in the vanguard of
collaboration and innovation tc's power
to shape the learning century knows no
bounds you will be educating future
generations of health professionals or
running clinical research trials you
will be developing new strategies to
raise science literacy and math skills
or inventing the digital tools that
allow us to study and evaluate teaching
methods and improve learning you will be
quantifying economic returns on social
investments or making headway in the
brain sciences you will be leading a
school or a university or leading the
way as a policymaker and improving
public education indeed TC has prepared
you to be innovative leaders in any
endeavor you choose our cheesiest Miller
who was born into a family of educators
always knew he wanted to help
disadvantaged youngsters in his native
Georgia he wasn't sure just how he found
the answer at TC thanks to a faculty
member who suggested that he start a
school of his own now with a TC masters
degree in educational leadership art
easiest will be returning to Georgia to
launch the utopian Academy for the Arts
a charter school that will serve
primarily african-american and Latino
students from grades 5 through 8 in
Clayton County one of the nation's
poorest school districts well done art
easeus
all of us at ECR proud of Lenore Kara
her title of executive administrative
assistant in the vice president's office
of diversity and community affairs
barely scratches the surface on the role
she plays in advancing equity of TC or
on her life story not long after earning
her undergraduate degree during the
1950's Lenore came to work at TC six
years ago in order to be closer to her
son Tim who was dying of AIDS with a
rare combination of sensitivities street
savvy and sheer determination Lenore
somehow managed to be there for Tim
served TC as a consummate administrative
professional and earned her master's
degree in post secondary and higher
education now that she's just become
yesterday or today the grandmother of
twins Lenore is thinking about pursuing
a doctorate possibly in early childhood
education Lenore you are a testament to
the power of lifelong learning and a TC
treasure congratulations
graduates all of you could not have
picked a better time to bring your TC
education to bear on the most
challenging issues of the day indeed
this is a fabulous time for this future
of this group of Future Leaders to be
entering the world of government agra
Dean and the professions long ago
Emerson told a room full of future
leaders much like yourselves this time
like all times is a very good one if we
but know what to do with it graduates
this is your time your moment for
shaping the learning century keep adding
to the knowledge that you helped advance
a TC draw on the wealth of life-changing
experiences you enjoyed here build on
the friendships you made here and by all
means make your time the very best of
times for us all thank you
we have now reached the moment to
present the teacher's college medal for
distinguished service the highest honor
the College bestows we honor those
extraordinary women and men whose life's
work has advanced the cause of Education
while upholding tc's core mission to
foster excellence and equity in the
fields we serve the Distinguished
Service Medal has been given in past
years to Archbishop Desmond Tutu Coretta
Scott King Senator George Mitchell Pete
Seeger Tom servo Lee Shulman Spike Lee
and many others this year our medalists
our eminent exemplars former New York
Times columnist and author Bob Herbert
Baltimore City Schools CEO dr. andreas
Alonso and Stanford professor and
education scholar former TC professor
dr. Linda darling-hammond dr. Alonzo
received his medal at this morning's
master ceremony and dr. darling-hammond
will receive her metal tomorrow at our
doctoral hooding ceremony here to
present Bob Herbert with his metal is
our provost and Dean Thomas James
Thank You president Furman it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Yolanda Seeley
Ruiz assistant professor of English
education in the department of arts and
humanities dr. Seeley Ruiz will present
our medalist Bob Herbert
good afternoon it is an honor for me to
introduce mr. Bob pervert in the opening
of your masterful 2005 book promises
betrayed waking up from the American
dream you write a reporter making the
rounds will spin an inordinate amount of
time trespassing in the presense that
were so well understood by the old blues
masters the places ravaged by hypocrisy
and double-dealing hatred and murder
acts of terror and endless war these are
places where the suffering occurs and
that tell us about the times in which we
live in our error no other Reporter has
trespassed those presents so fearlessly
and passionately as you or told us more
about the times in which we live thank
you at the Newark star-ledger at the
Daily News in your work in television
and most notably as a new york times
columnist you have consistently targeted
injustice shone a spotlight on the
struggles of the less powerful and
argued for a more compassionate and
egalitarian world the journalist ta
Frank called you the only national
columnist at a major newspaper who
consistently writes about the issues in
our country that matter most yet seemed
to be covered least when the majority
loses his bearings frank wrote herbert
sticks with the same minority it would
be hard to find a column of yours that
does not reflect the truth of those
words yet if one effort stands out above
all it may be Kafka and tulia in the
july 2002 piece you wrote calling
attention to a tiny Texas town where a
team of so-called law enforcement
officers systematically fabricated
charges against and arrested poor black
residents that column provoked
nationwide outrage discredited Pachulia
police and
to mately or return many convictions of
innocent people
Bob Herbert in 2007 when teachers
college introduced its social studies
curriculum teaching the levees you were
the first the last and the only choice
to moderate the launch event quite
simply the central question raised by
that curriculum was what kind of nation
do we want to be this question is the
one to which you have devoted your
career and your life for that shining
body of work we are proud to award you
the Teachers College medal for
distinguished service
wow this is truly a great honor and I
want to thank dr. Furman and the
trustees and my good friend Yolanda
Seeley Ruiz and all of you for making
this great honor possible and for
allowing me to share in this wonderful
day of yours my cheaters on you know
I've been listening to politicians talk
about the need to improve the public
education system in this country
especially the education of our most
disadvantaged youngsters for most of my
adult life Democrats and Republicans
talk about it liberals and conservatives
barack obama and george w bush we've had
race to the top and no child left behind
and non-stop hand-wringing over the
black/white achievement gap I'm waiting
for Donald Trump to weigh in because at
least then I'll know that whatever route
he's taking I should head in the
opposite direction
what I do know and what all of you know
is that we're in very serious trouble on
the education front and there's no doubt
about that and after so many decades of
double-talk bad faith and in some cases
outright lunacy from people in high
places I have come to the inescapable
conclusion that the politicians are not
going to get us out of this fix what
we've allowed to happen to public
education in this country is
mind-boggling and deeply tragic it cries
out for wholesale change instead the
people in charge are cutting budgets and
hacking away like mad at school services
while at the same time telling the
public with a straight face that they're
improving matters by obsessively testing
students and taking every opportunity to
demonize their teachers
I am proud to have the opportunity to
speak at this wonderful ceremony today
because teachers college is all about
bringing the best that education has to
offer to our young people but I have to
tell you I look out at you guys and I
almost see you as firefighters rushing
to the scene to prevent the policymakers
from burning down what's left of public
education in this country you've got a
big job to do we've got a disaster on
our hands and anyone who thinks it's
limited to the stereotypical inner-city
neighborhoods or to black and Latino
youngsters is mistaken visit some of our
rural areas and rust belt towns and
cities and you'll find young people who
have dropped out of school can't find a
job in our turning with dismay enci to
drug and alcohol abuse crime and teen
pregnancy problems long associated with
urban ghettos are now big problems in
these smaller distressed communities the
prospects of these unemployed under
educated young people are often grim
indeed the New York Times ran a
front-page feature recently on a
methamphetamine epidemic that is
spreading misery through an economically
depressed region of the Ozarks in
Missouri marriage and stable family
lives are going by the boards in many of
these trouble communities children are
being born to parents who are choosing
increasingly not to marry and who in
many cases can't afford to set up
households of their own what's the
outlook for those youngsters in his
first inaugural address Franklin
Roosevelt told the American people this
is pre-eminently the time to speak the
truth the whole truth frankly and boldly
well one of the major troops we need to
face in 2011 is that in many respects
we've become an
underachieving society and education is
one of those areas in which we've fallen
down the United States used to lead the
world in the education of its young
people and yet now when the need for a
powerful first-class education system
has never been greater we seem as a
nation to have given up on that we can't
find the money or the will to do the
right thing school budgets are being cut
teachers are being let go libraries are
being closed music and art courses are
being eliminated as if they were
unimportant luxuries that our children
can do without but just as our problems
are not limited to the inner cities
they're not limited to education either
education does not occur in a vacuum it
occurs in the context of the single
biggest problem facing our country today
and that problem is its extreme and
growing socio-economic inequality the
United States is becoming a dangerously
fractured society on one side are those
who are doing extremely well that's a
relatively small segment of the
population which includes the very rich
the bankers the CEOs the hedge fund
managers on the other side are those who
are struggling economically and in many
other ways the poor what we used to call
the working class and a substantial and
growing portion of the middle class
nearly 14 million Americans are
officially classified as unemployed
millions more are working part-time
because they can't find full-time jobs
middle income jobs jobs that would
support a middle-class standard of
living are disappearing from our economy
at an alarming rate they're being
replaced by low-wage often dead-end jobs
which now make up more than
forty percent of the total employment
economy in the US 17 million Americans
with a bachelor's degree or higher are
working in jobs that do not require a
college education I'll get off the
statistics in a moment but I want to
point out that 44 million Americans are
poor and it's believed that nearly 17
million are living in extreme poverty
those are people trying to make it on
incomes of eleven thousand dollars or
less for a family of four eleven
thousand dollars that's destitution and
you know better than anyone how
devastating that is for children being
raised under those circumstances the
truth frankly and boldly is that
ordinary Americans are hurting while
money and political power is being
concentrated in ever greater degrees in
the gilded precincts of those already at
the top this is a crisis that is
threatening not just the livelihoods of
millions of American individuals and
families it's threatening the very
character of the nation itself despite
all the pretty talk about freedom and
equality and the American Dream the
levels of wealth and income inequality
in the United States are by far the
highest among all the developed nations
of the world as incredible as it may
seem the top one percent of Americans
the richest 1% own more than the bottom
ninety percent combined that just
shouldn't be all of history tells us
that extreme levels of economic
inequality the kinds of disparities that
we're seeing in the United States right
now are harbingers of disaster they
destabilize societies the last time
wealth was concentrated to this extent
in the United States was not
coincidentally just before the Great
Depression right now in the US the
middle class is
thinking and the ranks of the poor are
growing there is real suffering out
there the American dream itself is on
life support so where do you fit in all
this well I certainly appreciate your
profound commitment to the education of
our young people what I would like you
to do more I don't want you to just
teach the children of this society I
want you to fight for them I want you to
help us attack these grotesquely unfair
wealth and income disparities I have
nothing against the rich I wouldn't mind
being among them myself but I don't want
them to leave everybody else behind so
we need your help to turn this
devastating inequality around you can
start by paying even closer attention
than you're paying now to what's
happening in America think about all
those workers who have gone under in the
vast sea of unemployment think about the
once solid middle-class families who
have had to turn to food stamps and food
banks and the families that have had to
double up with relatives or friends
because their homes have been lost to
foreclosure or a job loss made them fall
behind in their rent think about the
poor people who have been hammered so
hard in this recession and the millions
of American youngsters in big cities and
rural areas in small towns and rust belt
communities who are out of school out of
work and all but out of hope and then
think about the kind of society you
would like the United States to be I
don't think you want it to be a society
in which the doors of opportunity are
being slammed shut and that's exactly
what is happening now when you fire up
the wrecking ball for Medicare and
Medicaid and Social Security at the same
time that you're shielding the wealthy
and the great corporations from having
to pay their fair share of taxes you're
doing great harm to the ordinary working
people the struggling families
America we're speaking the truth frankly
and boldly and that's the truth when we
spend hundreds of billions of dollars
fighting endless wars in Afghanistan and
Iraq while here at home we're firing
teachers cutting school budgets closing
libraries and letting the nation's
infrastructure crumble before our very
eyes than we're doing great harm to the
very fabric of this great land of ours
the problem is not that the American
economy has been unable to produce
enough wealth the problem is that a tiny
fraction of the people at the very top
has cornered most of the nation's wealth
how did this happen is it because the
very rich are so much more talented and
worked so much harder than everybody
else don't you believe it no it's not
because the rich are all geniuses it's
not that at all the answer was neatly
summed up by the political scientists
Jacob hacker of Yale and Paul Pierson of
Berkeley in their important book
winner-take-all politics they explain
the enormous and unfair tilt toward the
very rich over the past few decades this
way step by step and debate by debate
America's public officials have
rewritten the rules of American politics
and the American economy in ways that
have benefited the few at the expense of
the many that's how it happened with
their outsized political influence the
very wealthy rewrote the rules and we
ended up with a country and an economy
geared almost solely to their interests
you've got to help us turn this
situation around we cannot transform the
system of education in this country
without bringing an end to this extreme
economic inequality now I know many of
you are already civically engaged but I
would urge you to become even more in
gay
aged consider devoting even more of your
time and energy to public service form
alliances with others who feel strongly
about what is happening in this country
educationally and otherwise and then use
those alliances to bring pressure on our
public officials so many of whom are at
the beck and call of the nation's
moneyed interests let the world know
that money isn't the be-all and end-all
that our human capital must come first
that our children deserve lives that are
long and happy and exciting and
satisfying and that your commitment to
serving the interests of those children
will not be derailed by those whose
interests are solely the bottom line I
thank you for your commitment I thank
you for your commitment I thank you for
your efforts and you should be proud of
the achievement that has brought you
here today take a moment to smile and be
happy about that but keep in mind that
this is not just your special day this
is also your era your time to make your
mark to help fashion the society and the
world that we all live in and that all
of America's children will inherit keep
that always in mind congratulations and
good luck thank you thank you so much
I'm delighted now to present our student
speaker Stacey Johnson Stacey's
graduating with her master's degree in
international educational development
with a concentration in peace education
she has a bachelor's degree from
Colorado College before attending
Teachers College Stacy spent three years
teaching at a public high school in the
Marshall Islands during her time at TC
she's been active in the peace education
network she's also worked with the
Center for African education next year
Stacy will return to the classroom as a
teacher in the Baltimore public schools
please join me in welcoming Stacy
Johnson
thank you friends family fellow
graduates faculty and staff I am deeply
honored by the opportunity to share my
thoughts with you today I've always
loved school I love learning exploring
Andrea defining myself finding a name
for something I have always known in
books and in ideas I love the exchange
of experience and thought and the jolt
of accidentally brushing against someone
else's mind in class getting a glimpse
of the alien architecture of another
person's brain I have loved education in
spite of the abuses I and many others
encountered in its name I have loved it
in spite of the imposition of an
oftentimes narrow and brittle curriculum
though much of the energy and resources
of my schools were devoted to
controlling the student body to training
us to be compliant and obedient members
of society even then I sensed the
transformative potential in education
when I entered college I became acutely
aware of the gaps in my education while
I had lived with the understanding that
at my school was not a good school this
was my first confrontation with the
consequences of educational and equity
the most damaging voy de myan was the
lack of critical reflection I had never
been expected to question the absolute
truth handed down to me by teachers and
textbooks certainly not by politicians
and the press I have spent the last 11
years trying to correct this two years
ago I came to Teachers College looking
for answers having experienced the
consequences of inequity and of
conformist education firsthand as a
student then later as a teacher in the
Marshall Islands I knew that I was
unprepared to tackle any of these issues
in a systematic way I hoped the Graduate
School would teach me how to educate in
a better way than what I had experienced
and that it would point me to the
theories the case studies the answers I
needed to get in there and start solving
problems fortunately I did not find any
answers any easy answers in any book or
classroom
TV instead I found authors colleagues
and professors who challenged my
assumptions and encouraged me to
question my presence and my presumption
in every space in order to engage
authentically with the task of
transforming the system I had to
deconstruct my own understandings of
Education and power knowledge and
teaching I needed to consider my
position and my relationship to
authority within the classroom the
system and the community and most
importantly I needed to do this
constantly inevitably we will each
interspaces that are shaped by an equity
whether they be institutions of
privilege or those that serve the
marginalized as we prepare to inhabit
the roles of leaders educators and
practitioners I hope that we continue to
position ourselves as learners I hope
that we enter the communities schools
and organizations with humility and a
willingness to question not only the
structures practices and cultures that
perpetuate inequity but to question our
own roles and supporting ignoring or
dismantling them I hope that we
appreciate the enormous responsibility
that accompanies the role of educator we
frequently emphasize the power of
Education to liberate to enrich to
illuminate and I am deeply committed to
bearing this out of my own work but we
must also recognize the darker power of
Education the power to alienate to
shudder to engender intolerance or
apathy we must ensure that the phrase is
critical thinking and social justice
become more than hollow banners they
should be evident in our relationships
with the classrooms the communities and
the organization's we enter but they
should also be carved into every aspect
of the way that we live as graduates of
teacher call at Teachers College an
institution with a social justice
mission indeed as human beings we have a
profound responsibility to cultivate a
culture of inquiry and critical
consciousness in our work and in our
lives lettuce embody the transformative
power of Education in our constant
evolution as individuals and as
professionals as we grow in our capacity
to question to see clearly
for each other we begin to fulfill the
promise of education that drew us to
this institution thank you and
congratulations good afternoon for many
of you I had the distinct pleasure of
welcoming you to Teachers College when
we first admitted you for some of you
this was this past year for others maybe
the year before and let's just say for
some of you it was just a very very long
time ago but congratulations to all of
you on this amazing achievement today at
this time it gives me great pleasure to
read the names of those candidates for
the Master of Arts Master of Education
sort of philosophy and Master of Science
degrees at Teachers College Columbia
University
all of your degrees will be conferred at
the Columbia University ceremony
tomorrow I will be reading the names of
degree candidates who registered to
participate in this ceremony by April
23rd this is not the complete list of
students graduating tomorrow so rest
assured if you are cleared for
graduation by the office of the
registrar but your name is not called
we're not going to take it back names of
the candidates will be read in
alphabetical order by Department when I
call your name please stand and then be
seated we ask that you hold your
applause until all the names for each
department have been read thank you very
much and now the candidates for the
Master of Arts Master of Education
master of philosophy and Master of
Science degrees from the department of
health and behavior studies
Melinda bath Abbott Sarah Abrams indira
Acosta Elizabeth alexis dziena Elmo saw
michelle lee Amos Carla Anastasio April
Sanderlin asa lemus mom dau a ballad on
Andrea Beal Donna fiala Diane playhut
Allison Elizabeth Bowers Amanda Theresa
boil Allison Gwendolyn Mary Brown Nicole
Ellen buck christina koski on Reba
Patricia pan Chang Carlene chin michelle
lynn Cimino luchia Conte Colin Michael
Cox Josephine Margaret cuda and therese
Dubrow Carrie Patricia daily megan marie
de ferro Christina barbara jordan ski
Jillian Mary Jocasta Rachel Susan de
looper Mary Kathleen day Louise angela
maria grazia DiMaggio aarielle a snicka
which sara fay Douglas
Mary Kay Doyle Sarah Christine Drake
Katherine Amanda Dressel Daniel Ron Falk
Janie Feldstein lisa marie pennsic Julia
Floyd Gina porcelli Suzanne Francois
Maxine frere Sarah Gabler Valerie
jean-pierre Jabara Justine Elizabeth
gervacio Jennifer Eileen Justin yani kia
grab n ski Dion lenee Alicia green
Elizabeth a madani william arthur hall
nicole marie heller Helena song a han
Marsha Charice Hayes westy Grosch
Hennessey see young une hong-an hoober
antonina I anatolli nera heka jaiswal
carrie Ann Jennings Gabriel kimberly
johnson janae kara Jones jarek Matthew
Jones Tina be Kafka sukhman jerk hour
Alexandra Brooke Kizer Elizabeth coil
kiernan Jennifer Jane Kim Rachel cobran
nancy elizabeth cone bonny Lee Cynthia
Cholula Lee Amy Rebecca love it shamong
Lee crystal lowe Janet Polanco Lopez
Laura Elizabeth Lions Elizabeth Presley
McGrath Brielle Renee meskin Tracy Elise
Messer megan rose miller Jamie mock
Noreen l Myers right Alexandra mistress
anastasia iris Nevin Drago slob
Novakovich Anna a repository Christina
Papa Constantius
Haley Elizabeth Pellegrin Maria Lisa
Perry amy Lynn Pettibone Amanda Charlene
Philip Brittany and powell Natasha raker
Kaitlyn and Russia is about seen we re
Kelly and Sager Elizabeth Teresa
salmeron Elizabeth sarto Molly Claire
scotch Dana Nicole Selznick Jill Sherman
Daria shevchenko orly sharone show
Meredith sue so bone ana cristina
Spencer Tanisha s Stanton Joo Eun Cassie
sung s lotta he'd ajua today Lauren
Christine Thomas Megan Jane Tully
jordana Rose Vigoda Betty Wang Judy Lee
Anne Wong Leah and wasserstrom Elizabeth
grace woods shlomit you yeah Jeju will
the students and the faculty from the
department of health and behavior
studies please stand and be recognized
and now the graduates from the
Department of Human Development a nut a
mere shreed grace no Vaska atienza
Lauren Louise Bates Barrett Glen beard
Wilson bonito Julia's ethnic Benjamin
melissa lee brunette fabienne k Blake ji
sung cha Tarini rauch Allah you are
young choi you n me chor Corran Natalie
& Cruz Vanessa Jay Bell kaliesha shaquan
Daniels Justin day off Angela Nicole de
Martinez Pamela Ellis Guidry Christina
Nicole L she Brian William farmer
Jessica Aviva forouzan Caitlin Patricia
Fuentes jia jiao courtney elizabeth reza
Kowski Eric Andrew hawk Cathie Jung Han
Sarah aberdeen Harrison maria lara huang
Sakiko a coma Seth Stanley prathima soup
mean khong Louise Kushner Samantha joy
Laszlo zhang Wan Li Ming saw and Pierre
Lou joseph edward lachine ivana Lou talk
man Courtney Francis may on em rule
mazeed Janelle Hannah McHugh Joyce mixin
quinta Dufresne mochilas Matthew L
Morris
Sabella um Kaylee Nicole Noel Tara
O'Leary Lisa shalin pow Anna Park mean
ha pop Christopher Dale Peterson
Rochelle t Pope Yeo Jin ring Amanda
Christine Reeves Anna Celia Rodriguez
Humberto a bell Rodriguez Josie liya kar
lena de daniel sallu Nina lynn sears
Carla Samantha Seaver Fallon alessandra
Shepherd shall when she Lisa Simmons
francisca studs Michael Isaac's wart
Sarah Sweeney Antony tan Kristen be the
NEMA don don wong Francois sworn ham
jason s wolf kshama right rayshawn
ji-sun you will the students and the
faculty from the department of human
development please stand and be
recognized
and now the graduates from the
Department of International and trans
cultural studies Nicole and Adams Sheila
Karen L our son Adelina Anna Sophie and
our Kellen Elizabeth Atkinson Alexis
Sarah Austin are yon barham Beijing
Jessica Louise ball yu kyung bomb
Samantha Joan bacilli Heidi Noel
batchelder Catherine Eva batchelder mark
c Beasley Marie Maria Jose bermeo sabria
Anika brown Dorothy Josefina Cal dome
Laura can takea Allison Chang nermeen
shatila Li Chen you pin Chang Cara
chesil a nice to John Choi
elisheva Cohen Daniel Marion Cooper
Celine Therese Torres cordova avi
critten Camilla Diaz add weenie Rhoda
lean digesta Kathleen aspell Dowling
Tara Catherine ekberg mark fox Ellen
Louise frierson Archie gagney z Patricia
micho Gibson Laura Elizabeth Giles Corey
aki Anna green iono victoria how cologne
Ryan Charles Hathaway Revitol Heller
Constance Honaker Nicole Francis hornig
joy seen Vong Kimberly Arlene Jackson
stacey lee johnson sonam sure Johnny
Sara Elizabeth call men Rita naina
kimani Alexandra caption Aaliyah Kareem
prema Kelly Cynthia ji hee kim hye jung
kim in june Jessica Kim Chi hey Kim
Sharon Kim gregory james Landrigan high
n li maria lean David let a chap ski
cristille a gen Lee Kieran liquori
Shuang Shuang leo un ting leo the O show
n henry Michelle Lopez never rat Johnny
y la Ola Maria Alexandra Minaya Colette
grace mother Shelly shantal McGill
Bridget Ellen McLaughlin Jason see melon
kara Rupa here to tin VIN win doc when
Nancy Ojeda mata estrella Liliana
Oliveira's Oriana gee who Park Sung Jung
POC su un park amy Lynn hoarder ashley
marie Prather Margaret price Kristen
Quackenbush sri lanka ramat goo rao
Catherine rose Reddington Alison
Meredith role weekend monfriez aha
Laurieann Salazar I'm rappel tower
sandhu shwetha I ishan v amber Melissa
Schwab he's young sim joseph alexander s
mirman leviton megan Maurice need chi
hieu on song Catherine Tierney Stidham
surat mood of stoppage to gave Latonya
Taylor joy Midori sosua Karen Velasquez
Charles matthew vaughn Rosenberg to
Shonda nicole washington shooting way
nicole grace Whittier and Elizabeth
wiley Catherine wise men Sabine Xander
will the students and the faculty from
the Department of International and
trans cultural studies please stand to
be recognized
and now the graduates from the
department of mathematics science and
technology
Nicole Mandy Abramson Samantha Jane
Addams Samuel J on Carrie see Ellen
Victor Kwame ashura jean-marie bakes fit
zoom billing Eric James benzyl Victoria
leaf / toddy Patricia Murray Brent
quarry Emmanuel Chapman Jennifer Chen
Peter Jung meanchey shamara coward
Allison Elizabeth curry leah marie de me
know kristin leigh Delle Donne a
sergeant Donovan Smith deepa Rebecca
Eddie it awara dobara aku boo Brian
Catherine Harper Exim Lacey Alexandra
Friedman Adrian and Garber Gerald
Gleason Patricia and glisan edward john
halah seen
sheehy Hong jennifer and jaswal Laura
Ellen Johnson Mindy k Johnston Alexander
tube or Jones Kristen josephson jameel
Kabir Erica L can't or Adrian crystal k
hyun jung kim GE kim yong Eskom megan
nicole King car we Co pamela Louise
kornbluh Anna Liana Domna goulash dilara
manoj rataj Joel ah see em qua be Victor
mean la Beth devorah Latin now n lee
kuan yew yuen hiddy li shi jia lean
Emily liao hi lean Mary lokahi karina
leo Luke Patrick Malone Catherine man
jennifer marie Caitlin Delaney McCaffrey
Daniel P McVeigh Cara Milan Morris
Vanessa Trinette muy Donna Murdock talay
de jure Nesbitt
johanna talavera owe me are Annette oz
ban Carla saboteur palacios Whitney
Alexis Elizabeth Powell League me prove
all Daniel J Rabinowitz Kelly and read
Oksana Resnick ova shanetta an Tina
Richardson Jenna carry Robbins Heather
Lisa saxa Christina Patricia Salazar
hard oh soo pasa road Colleen Catherine
shop Rebecca Dina Shapiro Vasu muzie
Sibanda Francesca antonina Sokka leg
Jacqueline Ginny Sorenson Paul Joseph
Stengel Lori and Stephenson hartano
hardy t joe anthony arch tricarico
daniela Ruth Omer Courtney Lee wagons
back un wang samara whites Beatrice
burlingame white Deborah Maria rate
delsey on right mark young Christine
Marie zaremba will the students and the
faculty from the department of
mathematics science and technology
please stand and be recognized and now
the graduates from the Department of
organization and leadership
Ruby a a ba bo Fernandez baba boonie
Allah funmi Leo at Alana Seth oh say
Agyemang Jenny Lee elshire Mitchell
Alexandra Alex Robert alluro Hollis
Murray amli Jasmine s poor George a
Albert Jessica a Balboni nika Lynn
balague Nathan Alexandra pup cheese
desislava bear mug Greg and batchelder
Jamie Debose Derek Barbra Jean Beachley
Sara Elizabeth bony's Shire Dahlberg
Monica Lynette Benton Palmer sumat bot
Michelle Sarah biller leaving Carol
Denise Burke's Michael Edward black men
mary-kate Blaine Tara block Brett Howard
lemur
Margaret booth Marcus hilton bowers
james e grant Christina francisca Rosita
Julie Ann Marie brockway Emily Bronstein
adina Barrios Brooks Peter Jacob Brooks
scott david bruss Mary Kathleen Buckley
Tamara a bunnell k mu assigned bynum
Angela Lynn Carrasco adriana de pilar
carrillo ishara casella's cats April
cash Catherine and Cebulski Cordelia o
ye Incheon swati Shandra Darren Michael
Chavez Stephen J tiger Joshua t Christie
Sookie Chung
lara Mijares samee see on Robin Kathleen
Clanton benjamin joseph Cody Casey
Oneida cali air Michael Ryan Coppola
Terran cowan kristen elizabeth Creech
Margaret and chrome the set Lynn cruise
ian MacDonald Cummings liesebet Cpl
Brandon Eric Davis jose manuel de his
ooze Amy Jill diner Kristen Jean demers
Nicole jus Jordan Mary Catherine Dylan
Polina dole dole onopka john william da
hah Jessica Slater Donovan Stewart hutch
endorsing Amy Elizabeth Downey Chanel
Marie duck Thomas Covington dire hernan
from selden L refine shineray I union
hall Choate ericsson Mary Reed Ervin
daily chatel Marie Estevez Lopez
geoffrey alan evans
Rashid face all Laura Diana Falcone john
irwin fonts Peter Harris Feldman
Magdalena Fernandez Chris fields
Nichelle Aaron Fisher john paul
Fitzgerald hope a Flanagan Angela
janiece flowers Alouette meola be follow
Rancho cray mahalia Francis Darlie
Franco Nisa Frank Colleen Mary friend
Miguel Angel free us Jeremiah see Fred's
Jill sarah froman Kevin Matthew phoner
Francisca Alma Ingeborg funk
raymundo Carlos Gaby jr. Jennifer
Patricia Galvez young cow Derek dhigay
horrid janati hi Juan joy gearing
michael patrick Gibbons gregory s Gibson
Steven Gildea Emily Catherine gershon
leiria Azam's idea Rodney Maurice
Glasgow marcin Jose ich kann Gonzalez
Robin page Greenwald James Jason
Greenwood Christina Michelle guzzo
Sharon ha Alexis Danielle ha kovitch
jolie Renee Harris kara Siobhan Hayes
Jacob hazard Elizabeth Marie Hernandez
Samuel ogden Herrick Mollie Brennan
Hogan Catherine Alice Cooper
Rihanna and Hubert versi knee i er
Jessica Joshua's rajendra Jimenez hi all
Johan Joe Eric Ivan Johnson Jerome
Fredrik Johnston Melanie Elizabeth
McPherson Jones Jolene leola Joseph
Catherine Kaiser Lenore Cairo andrew
bishop cash brag Michael Scott Keller
Imani hegde eight kitab you lean Kristen
core Joanne quarry free us ass off
Alicia climb Patricia and nah Warren
Michelle Koenig Doris Elizabeth kurta
Jacob and rage Lao Aaron Nichelle least
in Snyder Sophia Lee Nichole Lipari
opolis
Donovan Albert Livingston Jill may bruh
Logan Kathleen Mary Lynch Marissa meg no
Stella and Mayor Edgar muhrtelle Glennis
and Marquez Patrick Anthony Martinez
Nicholas Brandon martucci Samuel and
mcallister michaelia McCarthy Sean
Joseph McCarthy nicole danielle
mcfarlane mckenzie lee mack Amell Terran
flavel McKnight Gordon john mcneill
Malik Deepak neta Angela Murray the
klavik art easeus Monta Miller Aaliyah
Candice mins munesh mola Lauren banks
boom Jocelyn Morales Kenneth Scott
morally Michael priest al Morris tia
Renee Morris June Morrison Jones Margo
Walton Moses
Katie nikolaev mosher by yuko murasame
Adriana Marta Murphy rob e Nash hosey
Daniel Neal die van when Julie when
Lawrence in-joke ooh Alexander O'Donnell
Northrup Courtney Jane nuns Diana
Catherine Brooks O'Donnell Hadiya II
O'Neill Christie and O'Neill laura
michelle o'neill brian michael ogden
Carolyn Carolyn Okabe Jessica aastra
Amanda Lee odd Randy t Overstreet
Valerie f Amina oh-ohlow Eugene W pakka
Stephanie Charlene Paris Cooper
Carlisle Barrow paul andrew nielsen
pecunia annarita pergolesi Wentworth
James Smith Perry Matthew Leon pilarski
Barbara Jimenez punish Adam Fitzgerald
puli Melissa Diane powers Lisa present
ELISA puglia Louise g'quan sarah
elizabeth rao sees our F Ramirez Jud
dear Edmund Zachary Alden read Noah
Harry Dena Reinhart Matthew Owen running
her William Richardson joana rivera
esperat Kathleen Joan Robinson John Mark
rockland Frieda Carolina Rodriguez John
Anthony Rogan oh the third Jennifer
kotler romana
David are roses Allison hey Lee Rosen
blue Alex Antonio rosero tonyamarie Roth
Michael Joseph risky d Jacob Ruza neck
marleny a shocks acronym Margo and Xiao
yonathan choise mer Ilana hillary scott
Sheila Bridget Serrano near v Shaw
Andrew Dana shaw / dude kumar's shell
robert andrews schaaf megan lin siphon
har Elaine Octavio saverio Rachel siman
tov virginia way con su Stanley clay
Smith Michael v sojka Christine st. John
Melissa Jane steel Scott steel Margo
Sarah Stein kara Ingrid Stevens Rebecca
and stillwell June you sue Robert
Jeffery sudderth Vicki tan Benjamin
Lewis temple Jaleen Spain thomas anthony
r thompson Margaret ting Catherine and
Titus ruth e Torres Christine sigh
Elizabeth Jeanette Turner Archie em
Tyson nataya viro victoria alyssa valdez
Vasquez Ellen Tina red onion Linda
Marlon Vasquez yelitza our Vasquez
charles anthony vergara Dwight Gerald
the doll Jeffrey Aaron vinicor parinda
Vera Nova
Ruth and Waldo Alison Louise walling
Patrick Walsh jian wang Carlin Edward
Washington Jason Robert Wayne Jonathan
wellerstein Caroline may well T Jamie
Wendell Kenneth Grayson white Robert
clifton White House Michael Arthur
Williams Tony graves willemsen rachel
louise willis andreen Lysette wilson
eric wynn fire Yvette Brooks winter
Megan and Whitman honey whoo quanta
young Bonnie yay honey jagiya zoo Ryan
Christopher Patric Young will the
students and the faculty from the
Department of organization and
leadership please stand and be
recognized
and we'll all of the graduates and our
faculty please stand and be recognized
and now Provost Thomas James please be
seated president Fuhrman mr. Rickard mr.
Hyland trustees faculty and guests it is
my pleasure as Provost of Teachers
College to prevent you two masters
candidates from teachers college please
hold your applause until all the
candidates have been recognized with
those receiving the Masters of Arts
please stand be recognized and remain
standing
masters of science please stand be
recognized and remain standing masters
of philosophy please stand be recognized
and remain standing masters of education
please stand and be recognized and
remain standing president Furman I ask
you to recommend these students for the
granting of their master's degree
tomorrow morning at the Columbia
University commitment exercises thank
you please be seated
I'm Robert Weintraub president of the
Teachers College Alumni Association it
is with great pleasure that I formally
welcome you our newest alumni into our
community you are joining a body of some
90,000 professionals from all our
departments and programs in all walks of
life at all stages of careers who have
made a significant mark in the world
they have done so because of their
intelligence sensitivity drive knowledge
experience and wisdom they have also
done so because of the people like the
ones around you today family friends
teachers administrators trustees
benefactors and fellow alumni
representing our alumni I am here to
tell you how valuable participation in
our association can be we are colleagues
and collaborators supporters and
challengers advisors and networkers and
what holds us all together is our alma
mater if your time here was anything
like mine you experience moments of
puzzlement angst and weariness along
with insight inspiration and laughter
and many of you have developed what will
be lifelong friendships if your future
time here is anything like mine I can
assure you that your continued
connection to TC will continue to bring
you in sight inspiration laughter and
friendships right now I know that your
focus is and should be on your work and
careers you are destined to do important
things in education development health
care and organizations but please know
that you have a home and rich community
in
see which you can tap into physically
and virtually your fellow alumni along
with all the people here that make
Teachers College special wish you all
the best in your endeavors and we hope
that we have the opportunity to join you
along the way
hello I'm bill rickard co-chairman of
the board of trustees on behalf of all
of the trustees of Teachers College I
want to congratulate each of you on your
very special achievement we thank your
families and friends for joining with
the faculty and staff of Teachers
College in recognizing you our masters
candidates of the class of 2011 one more
time
thank you all for joining us today we
ask that family friends and guests
please remain in your seats until all of
the students have left congratulations
you
and we'll all of the graduates and our
faculty please stand and be recognized
and now Provost Thomas James please be
seated president Fuhrman mr. Rickard mr.
Hyland trustees faculty and guests it is
my pleasure as Provost of Teachers
College to prevent you the masters
candidates from teachers college please
hold your applause until all the
candidates have been recognized with
those receiving the Masters of Arts
please stand be recognized and remain
standing
masters of science please stand be
recognized and remain standing masters
of philosophy please stand be recognized
and remain standing masters of education
please stand and be recognized and
remain standing president Furman I ask
you to recommend these students for the
granting of their master's degree
tomorrow morning at the Columbia
University commitment exercises thank
you please be seated
I'm Robert Weintraub president of the
Teachers College Alumni Association it
is with great pleasure that I formally
welcome you our newest alumni into our
community you are joining a body of some
90,000 professionals from all our
departments and programs in all walks of
life at all stages of careers who have
made a significant mark in the world
they have done so because of their
intelligence sensitivity drive knowledge
experience and wisdom they have also
done so because of the people like the
ones around you today family friends
teachers administrators trustees
benefactors and fellow alumni
representing our alumni I am here to
tell you how valuable participation in
our association can be we are colleagues
and collaborators supporters and
challengers advisors and networkers and
what holds us all together is our alma
mater if your time here was anything
like mine you experience moments of
puzzlement angst and weariness along
with insight inspiration and laughter
and many of you have developed what will
be lifelong friendships if your future
time here is anything like mine I can
assure you that your continued
connection to TC will continue to bring
you in sight inspiration laughter and
friendships right now I know that your
focus is and should be on your work and
careers you are destined to do important
things in education development health
care and organizations but please know
that you have a home and rich community
in T
see which you can tap into physically
and virtually your fellow alumni along
with all the people here that make
Teachers College special wish you all
the best in your endeavors and we hope
that we have the opportunity to join you
along the way
hello I'm bill record co chairman of the
board of trustees on behalf of all of
the trustees of Teachers College I want
to congratulate each of you on your very
special achievement we thank your
families and friends for joining with
the faculty and staff of Teachers
College in recognizing you our masters
candidates of the class of 2011 one more
time
thank you all for joining us today we
ask that family friends and guests
please remain in your seats until all of
the students have left congratulations
you